اذا مشاهدينا هذه الصور التي وردتنا الان
للاستهداف الذي ذكرناه في بدايه هذه
النشره لمنطقه الكلاكله جنوب الخرطوم اذا
هذه المنطقه والمنازل السكنيه تعرضت
لاستهداف يقال بانه للطائرات بحسب توثيق
وتداول لبعض الصور على وسائل
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي هذه الصور
الحصريه للعربيه للمنازل المستهدفه طبعا
الجانب الطبي تحدث عن سقوط سبعه مدنيين
قتلى في هذا القصف عدد الجرحى بالعشرات
ولكن لم يتهمه لم يتم تحديد العدد بالكامل
اذا صور حصريه للعربيه تظهر منطقه
الكلاكله جنوب الخرطوم بعد تعرضها وتعرض
منازل المدنيين فيها لقصف جوي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات